The solution to this is to provide some kind of northbound API, which is a
programming interface that allows applications and other kinds
of orchestration systems to program the network. So
where we have at the low-level the
controller updating state in the switch using OpenFlow
flow modification rules we may have applications or
orchestration systems that need to perform more sophisticated
tasks, such as path computation, loop avoidance,
and so forth. But we need a higher-level
programming interface that allows these applications to talk
to the controller so the application isn't writing
low-level OpenFlow rules, but rather is expressing what
it wants to have happen in terms of
higher-level behaviors without regard to such things as
whether or not the rules are being installed
in a consistent, and correct fashion. Various people
may write these applications including network operators, service
providers, researchers, and really anyone who wants to
develop capabilities on top of OpenFlow. The benefits
of such a northbound API are vendor independence,
as well as the ability to quickly modify
or customize control through various popular programming languages.
The idea is that these applications might be
written in high-level programming languages, such
as Python, and wouldn't actually have to
perform low-level switch modifications, but rather could
express policies in terms of much higher-level
abstractions. Examples of such applications include the
implementation of a large virtual switch abstraction,
security applications, and services that may need
to integrate traffic processing with middle boxes.
This programmatic interface is called the
northbound API and currently there's no
standard for the northbound API, as there is for the southbound API
in OpenFlow. But we'll look at various APIs in programming languages that
each compile to OpenFlow rules that
are installed on switches across the network.